for the Germans joining protests in
recent days the country has been down
this path before many are worried The
Growing Power of the far-right afd party
carries Echoes of Germany's Nazi past
and they want to stop it this was
cologne on Sunday where tens of
thousands gathered on the banks of the
Ry
River I'm demonstrating against the fact
that the things that we all learned at
school that we all know can still seem
to repeat themselves and I'm here to
show that the silent majority is no
longer silent because we are the
majority I think our democracy is a
stable democracy and it must never never
be attacked in the way the afd is
currently attacking it since Friday
there have been big protests in Hamburg
Frankfurt stutgart nurenberg and Hanover
on Sunday it was cologne Munich and the
capital Berlin what triggered them was
the expose of a meeting held between the
afd and Austrian far leader Martin
selner where the forc deportation of
millions of immigrants and Germans of
foreign origin was discussed the afd
denied supporting the idea but it's been
a major Scandal nonetheless Nothing is
for
granted we have a strong Constitution
but we need a strong civil society and
we need in the center of the democratic
parties a clear cut a clear firewall not
to cooperate with this rightwing
extremist and not copy parts of their
agenda the afd was founded a decade ago
on anti-immigration and euroskeptic
policies most counts now put it in
second place nationally with about 20%
support and there are State elections
later this year in three regions where
the afd is leading the polls but the
many thousands of demonstrators who've
come to the streets of most major cities
are making the points that the afd
doesn't speak for them Rory chin
alzero make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer